foreign
[Music]
Bob you're up first okay you're on a
cruise ship ship encounters a storm the
storm rages on and on until eventually
you and the other passengers are told
you must head to the lifeboats and
Abandon Ship as you line up you realize
some lines have fewer people some have
families some seem to be younger
single people you know that you are
strong and capable
open-ended question hold on a second
yeah okay how about this yeah you see
that the line at the front line are
young PR uh families you know infirm
people not strong like you you don't
think you're going to make it on a
Lifeboat because this particular boat
does not have enough lifeboats to fit
all the people on the ship but the
ship's going down in about five minutes
it's going to be completely underwater
what do you do
[Music]
okay easy easy one uh I find the nearest
crew member and I uh knock them
unconscious
I steal their crew top shirt thing and
and their life jacket and their hat so I
kind of look like an official crew
member uh I hide them somewhere in
conspicuous it's frantic no one will
notice anyway and then I run to the
front of the line and I start helping I
run and I'm helping people I'm strong
virile helping people get into the
lifeboats at some point I look into the
Lifeboat and I oh what no what I'll come
look at it and then I hop into the life
mode and I and then I'm in the Lifeboat
and I'm looking around like I'm doing
stuff I'm helping people find their
seats I'm looking and I'm like oh your
life you're here let me fix your life
jacket and I just adjust some strap
eventually the Lifeboat you know reloads
down into the water set sail and I'm
totally fine everything's good I
whoa come look at this
all right uh Wade you're up next all
right
what would you do so I go and I light a
fire because this boat's going down
anyway what's the fire gonna do it's a
distraction okay
while the fire is burning I go and I
help a family you know there's not a
very long line this family gets into the
Lifeboat and I start to lower the
Lifeboat with like I imagine just like
some kind of crane system to lower it
down when I pull one of the levers so
only one half of the boat goes the other
half stays up tipping the passengers out
pull the levers back up hop in myself
drop it real quick so it lands and
crushes the family so they can't say
anything about what happened
and then I drive away while the fire is
burning people are moving more afraid
they don't notice what I did
[Laughter]
him a favor they might have been maybe I
did maybe it was a pretty moral act by
myself definitely was
oh that could have been
[Music]